in Athens marina the luxury yachts are
lined up despite the crisis there is
money a plenty in Greece but it's all
held by a few super-rich and not the
state hoping to change that the
government recently brought in a luxury
tax anyone with a yacht like this has to
pay that tax so do the owners of private
pools and fancy cars tax inspectors
rarely come down here and many wealthy
Greeks end up bribing their way instead
of paying taxes anti-corruption laws are
said to be stiff but are they really
that question takes us to the heart of
the capital to a district showing few
signs of the economic crisis it's here
we speak to the new man in charge of
Greece's fight against corruption you
honest indus a planarian media what an
epic a nice would be parking me access
we've seen a surge in small-scale
corruption in a large part of the
workforce has lost a great chunk of its
income pleased with him a blue energy so
to retain a living they resort to
corruption in the car it's your stare
and it's particularly rife among civil
servants that Israel copier buff dose
put us first in the effort to help
change that his agency is developing a
new strategy it's aimed at strengthening
the authorities hand through increased
cooperation it makes we put in place
powerful laws against corruption and
they are being implemented but the legal
system moves too slowly the police work
well but what's missing is cooperation
particularly between the various
agencies that's what we want to improve
to tackle corruption tin des wants to
see regular meetings of all those
involved in the fight including EU
representatives he hopes that will help
stamp out shady deals
youjizz the question remains how that
can be achieved at the circumstances
here do not change lawyers and
economists working for the government's
anti-corruption agency barely get enough
money just over a thousand euros a month
that means they have to seek additional
job to supplement their official pay
some things though are changing
organizations such as transparency
international's say there are signs of a
shift in Greeks mentality on the issue
the current government has arrested
quite a few people because that's
another good news we have seen a lot of
people going to the public prosecutor
but that is a wave which is on your wave
and if you don't make it a tsunami it
won't it won't help indeed things are
unlikely to change if that wave doesn't
spread to Greece is super rich the ones
who could surely afford to do without
corruption